that's not the plan
yeah I just drove by your uh
defunct restaurant yeah yeah
yeah cause was your mom running out they
just fixed the uh the the windows and
[__] my mom was running it I mean that's
probably the problem huh
no I was running it and we just kind of
fell out and then I mean we've seen yes
okay he's like kinda like this fell off
but I partnered with somebody else uh
you should put one in her Hood over
there in the valley and make it like
Ceviche bruh like you know the Mexicans
gotta go straight Mariscos bro I'm
trying to get a seafood you know in the
bag you know like they charge you like
crab legs yeah like crab legs
uh yeah dude you have a really
tumultuous relationship with your mom I
think I said that word wrong by the way
um but is there any repair in that
because shit's gotten super my mom is
far gone brother
I feel like when people get around me
poison my like clout fans and followers
and attention and then it's like
I'm not gonna fight with you about it
I'm not gonna call you and be like hey
why did you do this why did you do that
I'm gonna just be like
the more I see you going your way I'm
Gonna Go My Way you've been around this
mom a long time for a long time do you
kind of see the night and day of it
because I think that she yeah you know
her too I think that honestly I think
that she doesn't take the internet is
seriously that it is like
she'll like post something and then not
think it's that serious but then it is
that and then it's everywhere you know
what I mean and like because it's a
reflection and she's a she's a Leo so I
kind of I have like I want to say three
or four Leos in my life so I know that
they like they can get angry or they'll
want to say something and then they'll
say it and then be like that was crazy
was when she talked about the size of
your manhood I was like this should not
it I'm scared my dick way bigger than me
no I don't know
because I just think that I think that
it is way more I think she said it in a
way that she didn't mean it as like that
but right people people dissect and take
things in a way different way that you
like he could post something right now
and it would be so not like that they'll
dissect it slow it down who's in the
back what's on the counter that's the
type of that's where we live at though
that's the generation right now like
they want to find something wrong so she
she is giving them everything she is
crazy she is all that we but you like
that's who she's always been she's
always been you still get to see the
kids yeah she does I do I handle that
more so than him he doesn't I don't
listen food look here I don't want to be
in charge of no kids I don't want to be
responsible
this is great no I will look listen wait
let me land the kids are fine let me
learn I mean listen oh that's why I'm
gonna get finished okay that's why she
hasn't worked because I know you know
when I have kids with people I I don't
like
people
exactly one experience but yeah but when
I had kids with her I was always happy I
was always sure I was always like
I'm not a babysitter bro I'm a provider
a leader protector that's what a man is
to me somebody who's going to provide
lead and protect that's all I know how
to do so you're not interested in like a
day with the kids at Disneyland just you
know definitely he could never do he
could definitely do that though that's
about it though maybe if they're maybe
if they're like like walking they can go
in the bathroom
no diapers no bottles none of that like
we all eat the same thing and stuff
maybe absolutely then he I I think he
could yeah
like but diaper bag formula he is so
nice I gotta get out there and get it
bro yeah okay he's still not doing it if
I'm if I'm in the Gerber if I'm smoking
a baby how am I making any money for the
baby so you're not doing the airplane
and you know how much it cost to raise a
baby it is you got a reason for 18 years
oh trust me I know it costs about wait
listen yeah I have my kids it costs
about it costs about ten thousand
dollars a month buddy you're who you I
have grown children there's 12 months in
a year that's 120 000.
ten thousand dollars a month it costs
ten thousand dollars I mean
for your baby to have a room a bed
a school a ride to school food to eat at
school it cost ten thousand dollars a
month
that kid's living well
hey I every every kid should live well I
liked it I liked it I should live well
depending on what happens with this kid
that you're expecting we might want to
walk back that figure a little to maybe
like three thousand dollars a month in
case they come at you for child support
no I'm not worried about that
because
I've made her good enough to use her
she's good she can use her name anywhere
and get anything she she wants she
doesn't need you know
so I'm not making her dependent of me I
didn't for you you're not interested in
babysitting I can't bro I'ma provide
lead and protect and babysit
I mean it's it's possible
yeah for one two days maybe even three
days